well thank you very much everyone King
Salman of Saudi Arabia just called to
express his sincere condolences and give
his sympathies to the families and
friends of the warriors who were killed
and wounded in the attack that took
place just recently just this morning in
Pensacola Florida the King said that the
Saudi people are greatly angered by the
barbaric actions of the shooter and that
this person in no way shape or form
represents the feelings of the Saudi
people who loved the American people so
much so that was just given to me by the
king of Saudi Arabia and I can tell you
it's a horrible thing that took place
and we're getting to the bottom of it
all of the investigators are there now
and they're studying it very closely and
terrible things and our condolences go
to the families and to everybody
involved including the wounded we have
some badly wounded people also and we
have to extend our condolences to them
and we'll be working with them all very
closely so I just wanted to let you know
that was from King Solomon well that's
all being studied now we'll have a full
report on it very shortly is this could
this be considered a Terrorism Act were
you ducking a reporter then yet but
we'll be talking about it very soon they
could have a lot of great people looking
at it and interviewing people in deaths
and it'll be a report and the report
will come out very soon thank you
[Music]
[Music]
you